Samsung just announced their s24 Series
so should us iPhone users be jealous
well I will tell you guys all of the
differences so you guys can make up your
own minds now I have to say that I was
very impressed with their short little
video they made great production quality
tons of cool effects even if it was just
a little bit cheesy but that is a great
way to show things off and of course the
phrase AI was thrown around everywhere
now recently I see yes I was making fun
of Samsung cuz everything was AI when it
was just marketing but I have to say
that I'm actually really impressed
because there are some legitimate cool
features with these new phones I think
being able to just circle something in
an image and have it instantly search is
going to be very useful that'd be
something that I actually would use and
then having that live transcript where
it can listen make your whole notes for
you and then summarize it that's
actually pretty cool as well and even if
the image editor isn't the most robust
compared to other Solutions being able
to just remove somebody right there on
your phone in seconds was also very
useful honestly I feel like apple is
kind of falling behind Siri is still not
great they need a major overhaul and we
do have some basic features built in but
it's just so minimal and I wish we had
more now I will say that we did order
the s24 ultra and the regular one we're
going to be doing some of those blind
camera comparisons that are just so fun
to watch of course our ultimate Hands-On
real world comparisons and I be
switching over and using the ultra for
at least a week and giving you guys my
honest opinion so make sure you guys are
subscribed now the s24 is a bit funny
because it's basically an iPhone 15 now
we have the flat front the flat sides
that literally look like an iPhone we
have a slight curve on the back just
like the new iPhones and that frosted
back uh with some different colors if
the camera bumps were more similar you
probably couldn't even tell a difference
and because the ultra now has a flat
display as well the bezels are nice and
even so that is a benefit they made the
camera cut out a little bit smaller so
that is great but the crazy thing is how
much stuff just seems to be copied from
Apple for example this thing now also
has titanium which I think just doesn't
make sense I thought Apple should use
aluminum instead because technically
aluminum is lighter and it's better at
dissipating heat um but they use
titanium for more for marketing now
Samsung has to copy them and the
interesting thing is that the iPhone 15
Pro Max got a lot lighter with titanium
instead of stainless but the Samsung is
only 1 G lighter and I don't think
they're using as much titanium as apple
is for example Apple everything's made
up of tit tanium including the buttons
where with the Samsung no they are not
they are still aluminum now when the new
iPhones launched we had issues with heat
a part of that is because of titanium so
I'm really curious about how the s24
ultra is going to perform and we will be
talking about performance in just a
little bit now the s24 ultra does look
very similar compared to the previous
few Generations we have a little bit
less curve on the side and now we have
all frosted or matte sides as well
because it's titanium the bottom
slightly switched over with a little
regular cutout instead of the little
grills for the speaker the S Pen is more
flat so it's a little bit more of a flat
design and talking about the front I
personally liked how we had a slight
curve on the Samsung that was their main
selling point for years but now it is
completely flat now if we talk about the
display it gets an insane 2600 nits of
brightness now now compared to 2000 on
the iPhone but what you have to keep in
mind is that that is a peak rating and
for a while we would see iPhones that
had lower ratings that would be brighter
than their Samsung or Android
counterparts because that top rating is
Peak where you might just have a little
bit of whites on the screen instead of
the full display so of course we are
going to test that in our Hands-On
comparison now going to the back into
the cameras this is where it gets
interesting because a lot of people made
fun of the iPhone that it got a 5x Zoom
not a 10x which Samsung has had for
years saying that it is way better now
if you take a look at our images from
our camera comparison in the dark the
Samsung could be a lot worse than
Apple's 5x and the Samsung could not do
5x portraits either or 10x portraits
with that telephoto and the iPhone could
making the portrait shots look so much
better because it wasn't digitally
cropped in and with s24 ultra instead of
having a 10x just like they went over to
Titanium now they went from 10x for
years down to 5x for their telephoto so
was Apple right all along now the
benefit is instead of being a 10
megapixel camera now it is a 50 so much
higher resolution than Apple's 12
megapixel and that also allows them to
have a larger sensor better
stabilization and it looks like we are
going to be getting 5x portraits from
that lens so that is going to be awesome
I love the perspective that you get
shooting portraits with a 5x lens and
with that one thing that I am jealous of
is the fact that it will be able to
record 8K video from not only the main
lens but the telephoto lens as well the
iPhone even though technically it could
do it on the main lens Apple has not
enabled it and when I was shooting video
side by side the 8K on the s23 ultra
actually looks great I wish I could have
that now I know people say nobody really
has 8K displays yet but if you can shoot
it ahead of time and it doesn't take up
much more space with the compression why
not have better quality video for later
now one major Miss with the s24 ultra in
my opinion is that they did not
incorporate chi2 Apple gave the whole
design with the magnets uh to the chi
standard so that they can use mag safe
on Android devices with 15 wat charging
but they didn't use it and I think that
sucks now of course you could still get
a case with magnets built in but why not
put it into the phone I think it might
be because they made it slightly thinner
of course you have a Spen which is
awesome so maybe they just didn't have
the room and they didn't want to make a
thicker device now a benefit is on the
bottom USBC looks like it's now going to
be 10 GB per second just like the iPhone
so it's going to get twice as fast so
that is really good and now let's go
ahead and talk about performance here in
the US market and some other markets the
s24 ultra is going to come with the new
Snapdragon 8 gen 3 and even though that
does not use 3 nanomer Tech like the
iPhone does it is actually a very
powerful design one thing I love is that
it's going to have Wi-Fi 7 built in so
it's futureproof compared to Wi-Fi 6E
coming out just on the new 15 pro and
pro Max but that's already outdated now
if we look at the rest of the
performance between the 8 gen 3 and the
a17 pro it is a little bit interesting
techroid on YouTube already made a great
comparison with the first phone that
came with that chip and when you are
loading up apps and switching between
them the iPhone still dominates the
snapdragons along with Google's latest
tensor G3 now if you're rendering video
which I don't know how many people do on
their phones surprisingly the A7 gets
beat even with the older snapdragon in
now this is due to the encoding engines
and apple actually hasn't updated them
for a couple years since the A14 but if
you're working with photos dang the
iPhone's a17 Pro is fast and if we
compare geekbench performance my
goodness the single core of the iPhone
Just Smokes the other chips and the same
thing goes with multicore performance
the A7 Pro is killer even though it only
has has two performance cores now as far
as gaming performance the new 8 Gen 3 is
incredible if you look at anu's GPU
score it really has beaten out Apple's
graphics performance in their phones and
with that looks like the heat is quite
hot on the new hn3 it is sucking a lot
of power now thankfully Samsung did make
their Vapor chamber cooling larger on
this phone so I think that when you're
actually going to be gaming for a long
time it will likely have no problems
beating out the iPhone that's probably
another video that we are going to make
and of course even though the battery
life is much larger on the Samsung in
the real world I'm confident that the
iPhone is still going to be better
because of its 3 animet design better
efficiency in general this is what we've
had for years especially if you're going
to game and it's going to suck more
power so overall I think the launch is
better than I thought it would be just
based off of the leaks previously but
you guys let me know your thoughts and
make sure you guys click that Circle
above to subscribe so you guys don't
miss out on our handson comparisons and
tests this has been Max and I'll see you
in the next
[Music]
video